Westbrook with the steal sends it up out  of his way he just got a little ahead of  himself a little too far out in front of  the skis as we like to say yeah well you  had a whole lot of meat left on that  bone with a cop headband we got got  pretty excited but you know he's got the  footwork to do that just probably not on  that particular play I was ready for the  Euro step we can we've seen a couple of  times well he tried to he tried to start  it but you know I was trying to start a  lawnmower and you know what it's cold  you got to crank it a few times it was a  tough move certainly that's nice use of  the window big strides move certainly  [Applause]